[Musique]
toutes les courgettes là les premières
ça va bien
bientôt comme une habitude avant même de
démarrer son scooter le téléphone est
déjà posé à côté du guidon 42 roues ce
livreur la roue le téléphone c'est c'est
tout le temps en conduisant ouais tout
le temps quand je reçois une livraison
c'est juste en tapant que je valide deux
jeunes sur trois vous ainsi avoir déjà
utilisé leur téléphone quand ils roulent
en voiture vélo trottinette ou scooter
comme ça quand on roule ça fait du bruit
on croit être en moto
c'est particulièrement marquant 33% des
utilisateurs de scooter à vous consulter
les réseaux sociaux trois jeunes sur 10
déclarent même jouer à des jeux vidéo ou
encore regarder des séries ou des films
tout en roulant
des ambulances trop pressé qui coupe la
route des automobilistes ne respectent
pas les priorités provoquant des
accidents
une altercation entre un cycliste et un
taxi à Paris rien de très original mais
quelques mètres plus loin les deux
hommes en viennent presque commun quand
une femme en veste bleue intervient
la convergence
moi j'ai vu j'ai vu le début
cette vidéo issue d'un live sur twitch
est devenu viral plus de 2,6 millions de
vues le calme a fini par revenir et
l'élu en a profité pour faire un peu de
politique en demandant plus de pistes
cyclables ah ça va
plusieurs sociétés d'ambulance privée
sonnent aujourd'hui l'alarme et dénonce
un système concurrentiel qui pousse à
rouler toujours plus vite
du Samu vient de tomber c'est une
urgence l'ambulance se met en route
Jean-Philippe papillon a 20 minutes pour
se rendre sur place à l'autre bout de
Lyon
c'est fait pour signaler un danger
monsieur ça n'est pas fait pour
stationner
attention les petits bouts de pieds là
super super stationnement ça ça c'est un
bon stationnement ça je pense pas non je
pense pas vous n'êtes pas des modèles
vous n'avez pas de vélo monsieur
et vous vous avez un vélo vous avez le
droit d'être là
[Rires]
on voit que c'est un enfer depuis
justement qu'on a voulu intensifier le
nombre de cyclistes dans la ville la
ville était plutôt réservée aux
automobilistes au piétons maintenant il
y a les cyclistes en plus est-ce que
c'est possible ou est-ce que finalement
c'est celle-là vont se répéter et un
jour malheureusement ça finira mal
la liberté
Margot le i qualifie quelqu'un qui
brasse vraiment du vent
inutile oui
pour que tous les gens qui m'ont permis
sur
inement voilà
je fais ça
tous les jours
c'est une information M6 des
perquisitions dans l'affaire du fond
Marianne un fond lancé en 2021 par
Marlène Schiappa et doté de plus de 2
millions d'euros pour la lutte contre la
radicalisation les enquêteurs
s'interrogent sur l'opacité de
l'utilisation de ces sommes et les
domiciles du préfet Christian gravelle
responsable de la gestion du fond et de
Mohammed Sifaoui principal bénéficiaire
sont actuellement perquisitionnés
et alors vous avez une collection alors
ça ça monte pas inspecteur des impôts il
collectionne les pièces en euros
et ben voilà ceci explique cela vous en
avez beaucoup j'en ai de quelques pays
quand même voici une cérémonie de remise
des diplômes assez classiques HC dernier
qui est le leader de Magic System
désormais titulaire d'un Master en
Management je me suis dit aujourd'hui
c'est le jour du jour je vais pas faire
des discours je vais faire ce que je
sais faire le mieux alors est-ce qu'on
peut aller au boulot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une mère de poisson mort sur les plages
du Texas des milliers d'animaux marins
ont été retrouvés échoués entassés les
uns sur les eaux le phénomène macabre a
été signalé sur des dizaines de
kilomètres le long de la côte en cause
un manque d'oxygène dans l'eau due à une
température trop élevée c'est ce que
l'on appelle de l'hypoxie
qui est un peu disparu c'est dommage
c'est oui
comme les os du Golfe se réchauffent
l'eau n'arrive plus à dissoudre
l'oxygène correctement
et ce processus est primordial pour que
les poissons et les autres animaux
puissent respirer
avec 33 degrés dans la région les
poissons se sont retrouvés piégés sur la
plage les habitants sont médusés par cet
épisode ça s'est déjà passé j'ai vu ça
deux fois c'est dingue en plus ça pue en
Équateur la scène à laquelle on assiste
et bien c'est une veillée mortuaire
plusieurs personnes sont réunies autour
d'un cercueil celui de Bella Montoya une
femme de 76 ans l'homme en noir c'est
son fils Gilbert soudain et bien il se
passe quelque chose d'assez incroyable
c'est son fils lui-même qui me l'a
raconté je vous propose de l'écouter
j'ai entendu des coups comme ça contre
le cercueil
non non non je ne veux pas boire un
verre faut quand même la sortir du
cercueil donc les les secours arrivent
vous voyez les images et ce cours qu'il
a sortent du cercueil il y a les
pompiers qui sont sur place qui vont la
mettre dans l'ambulance pour la ramener
à l'hôpital alors actuelle elle est
toujours hospitalisée elle est en soins
intensif elle est sous oxygène mais son
cœur est stable parce qu'en fait elle
avait un problème de coeur elle avait
été déclaré morte suite à un accident
vasculaire cérébral donc là aujourd'hui
son état est stable même si elle est pas
sortie d'affaires c'est plutôt
encourageant Arnaud le procès de
Jean-Marc Morandini pour corruption de
mineurs s'ouvre aujourd'hui l'animateur
se faisait passer pour une femme
Catherine Leclerc pour obtenir des
photos ou des vidéos de mineurs nues
ouais pour le en leur faisant miroiter
un rôle dans une série produite par
Morandini la fosse Catherine elle leur
disait alors il faudra après faire une
gâterie à Jean-Marc Morandini c'est
quelqu'un d'important il a honte de rien
lui quand même
pour prendre l'air partout naturisme
voilà ah bah là tu prends bien l'air
partout malgré son procès Morandini est
toujours sur cnews ce qui est quand même
un comble la chaîne la plus magnifique
pour tous chrétienne BCBG de France qui
parmi ces animateurs vedettes à un
[__] menteur et limite pédophile
et dans la grille ça enchaîne avec des
émissions sur la spiritualité catholique
l'archange Gabriel les dix commandements